foreign
people welcome to Australia commentators
the game's all here live in person at
one table yeah we're not all here this
is the volume we're all here
individually and they're just putting us
together and I am mid-journey and you
are Dolly clearly clearly I just like
that the um the the reflection on the TV
looks like a JJ Abrams lens fryer it
does yeah we're getting a get some like
we take down all of these lights and
just do this in complete darkness thanks
we're here at honestar in the
commentaries uh we're kind of talk about
Mandalorian season three it's not a
western anymore I don't know why you're
talking like that it used to be it was
yeah now it's um uh the uh Cameo
Carousel uh everyone everyone hops on
and then gets their own spin-off
um so we're gonna show the Honest
Trailer talk about it uh all of our
deepest darkest thoughts about it and uh
then show you some deleted scenes do
some uh questions some q a about the
show or about us about anything about
life you see my scar want to see my scar
I want to know how Danielle got these
scars
um I don't know if you want to talk
about that but you can't wait until the
end that'll be a teaser Danielle tell
you where she's been what's been going
on and then uh we'll tease with next
week's on his trailer it's a fun one an
unexpectedly fun one yeah nobody
expected this to be a fun one but I did
not think I was gonna like this when the
first trailer came up I was very
pleasantly surprised yeah so all that
and more starting now the mandelier
this is where we would pause for uh oh
[__] okay yeah no let's roll it yeah
let's keep going I have spoilers
and DeLorean
delete it I'm lower again
got a baby you see Decades of Star Wars
films and shows all leading up to this
moment or more likely you bounce
sometime around rise of Skywalker in the
Boba Fett show
no yeah
what sparkly
leave you regarding Star Wars oh I I do
think it was book a Boba Fett because
that's like when I was just like what
are we doing here like I don't I didn't
I don't
I like all of those characters it was
one of those ones where it's like oh you
don't always have to go back if there's
no story there that you're itching to
tell if someone gives you an action
figure and says here play with this doll
and tell you like how would you like to
play with this doll you don't have to
you don't have to yeah have a story you
want to tell uh which is kind of a part
of my problem so yeah where the the book
ends because for me it was rise of
Skywalker that one was like oh this
world is just a branding exercise for
Disney they're just trying to make these
for the sake of like playing down the
exact direct middle of an imaginary not
even a fan a consumer like this is this
is a made for a consumer film right now
and I don't know whatever whatever magic
George Lucas has conjured is is fully
dead and in the ground and or I
obviously love but that seems like it's
a completely different and or at this
point is almost like the exception that
proves the rule like I liked it so much
because it's not anything like any of
the other Star Wars stuff they're
putting out so like stuff I like is like
like Visions is cool where they're like
all right let's give this to someone
completely different to play around with
it and that's where Star Wars is right
now for me it's like you need to give it
to someone completely different with no
attachments to the franchise for it to
have anything left yeah I think for me
the the real the real sticking point I
think the real bone of contention
between myself and like the lucasfilm
team is like I and it's not I hate the
cartoons it's not I think the cartoons
are terrible like I don't I don't but I
think it is a mistake to Pivot this
entire franchise around these 20 year
old Cartoon Network shows and I feel
like more and more that's what's
happening like especially this season of
the Mandalorian season one of the
Mandalorian felt very much like here's a
Star Wars show it's going to be kind of
off in its own Corner doing its own
thing we're taking nods from classic TV
shows like westerns and putting that in
a Star Wars context great this season
feels like here are is a live-action
continuation of the cartoons like that
it just that's all
using the cartoons to draw from because
the cartoons are in turn drawing from
Legends right they're drawing from the
uh the extended universe and stuff like
that sure there's plenty of novels like
not too many of the cartoon characters
are like thrawns from a book yeah I mean
I they they they took the old school
extended Universe expanded universe and
like that's no longer Canon but it
definitely inspired a lot of what has
come but this season of this show has
the tone of a Cartoon Network series
right yeah more so than mandalor in
season one for example yeah so fully I
mean by the end of this season when it's
like the battle for Mandalore and these
like my new Doc Trooper suit and it's
all the toys and the clothes and the
costumes and the blasters and it's like
this is just the Cartoon Network shows
but done as a live-action show yeah oh
well all right keep going
but aimlessly along while Disney scans
the Galaxy for anyone to make them a
decent movie again it's gonna be a while
folks and after this season they might
put favro in carbonite too hey Google
the same the Mandalorian season three
Bounty Hunter turned many din jarin is
back and just like Star Wars fans he's
not 100 sure what he's still doing here
I thought you had completed your mission
in this grab bag of a season of
rejoining his church group
you are redeemed a bit of a retaking
planet Mandalore it is time to retake
Mandalore a dash of dark cloning
a pinch of piracy we're pirate kangorian
shards men now you'll answer to him and
a death star's worth of real estate talk
there's a beautiful parcel of it
let's move
the trade District closer to the
shipping terms griefcarga is offered me
attractive land on his independent World
hereby seed all lands from the Western
lava Flats to pull a canyon
cabin just outside of town I can set you
up with a shrine
stop
this reminds me of like when you go to
Vegas and you're in the hotels and
someone's like hey we'll give you like a
20 gift certificate if you go listen to
us do this presentation oh yeah
that's the main industry on Navarro is
timeshares yeah yeah I'm not opposed to
them going to uh episode of the week or
like monster of the week or whatever but
it felt like it was kind of the worst of
Both Worlds because they were trying
they were kind of it was just a like a
dark and or like a reverse of it where
they had these like three episode arcs
but they were sort of very unsatisfying
and the and the the adventure of the
week was corny and didn't really pay off
it just I don't know it's just execution
was bad like I'm not I'm not uh opposed
to them doing
self-contained serialized storytelling
no that was the good stuff in season one
was the like self-contained one episode
adventures and they do try to do a few
of those this year but it just seems
like like yeah I don't I don't know it's
it's so loose and it's so like not kind
of figured out I I got into it a lot on
Twitter about the pirate stuff because I
was like the pirate storyline is not it
doesn't really work as a story the
Pirates are not there's no nobody's
motivated the Pirates show up they're
like we're Pirates we want to drink here
I want a drink in this place and not
that place I'm having an arbitrary
argument and then if it just it feels
very arbitrary like a cart like a
cartoon like if you're doing an episode
of a cartoon a nemesis right and and you
know people are getting mad at me like
what about they're pirates pirates don't
need motivation they're Pirates they
they want to do piracy and I'm like I
disagree good storytelling is you know
why even if Barbosa is an evil pirate
you know why he's looking for that that
uh crateful of Aztec gold it's not just
I am a Pirate and I do piracy things and
I think that's what this show is sort of
becoming is like but I'm here to be a
pirate and I'm gonna do a pirates over
like oh yeah pirate I'm Mandalorian I'm
gonna beat you and then he does and you
can also you can paper over a lot of
two-dimensional characters in
storytelling with uh craft and they lost
their cinematographer that they had for
seasons one two and they lost um Ludwig
Goranson they lost they lost the music
guy so it's like uh we're just kind of
getting the B Team like Diet Coke
version of of Mandalorian right here
yeah I don't
um
yeah a lot of the and we talk about the
cameos and stuff later obviously that's
very like that can really take you out
of the experience of watching the thing
it's also I'm sorry if you're gonna have
lizzo come in please give her lines
humans can say
they're very Regal they give her a very
a very legal uh just one line a person
would say but that's that that's a great
I think that's another great example of
like that's a fun idea for a one-off
episode like conceptually like lizzo and
Jack Black are these weird Royals and
this they've got to investigate this
Droid conspiracy like all of that I
think works it's just underwritten
they're not interesting characters it's
not an interesting Christopher Lloyd's
character was just like I actually am
evil yeah I don't even feel like we
understand what plazier 15 is and how it
works and who lives there and what's
going on and it just feels so
undercooked so quick so just and like
the motivation behind that whole episode
is you just want to go talk to your
friends you don't have you just need to
go over to the field like don't you have
radio you don't have a communicator you
could just call your friends call on
your helmet phone it seems so arbitrary
and that's like that's what the whole
season felt like it felt it feels very
like not locked in tight storytelling it
feels very arbitrary like when they need
some something to happen it's like a
monster is gonna pop up from out of the
mountain and grab you you know yeah very
side questy yeah a season of side quests
uh let's keep going
this season takes place after Dan finds
the darksaber but before he closed
escrow on a two-bedroom in Navarro you
love Pedro Pascal as a Gruff older guy
taking a little VIP across a dangerous
landscape you love watching him overcome
his troubled past to form a makeshift
family with his charge you love when he
joins with an equally grow female
counterpart who comes to see the value
of his mission and you love taking
diversions from the a story for one-off
episodes that follow the people they
encounter on their travels so yeah it's
that show again sorry for repeating
ourselves but so do they constantly this
is the way this is the way this is the
way this is the way
oh
this makes you think about that
fastballs
uh I do like uh there there's a thing
that Emily swallow the the actress who
plays the armorer does where they she's
like their their leader like she's the
final arbitrator of what is the way so I
like that there's a lot of points where
all the other characters would be like
this is the way and then they all kind
of look to her and she does this little
like pause she like she always leaves it
for a second what's she gonna like the
like the Gladiator is the thumb to go
over down then you're like
that's great that's great yeah a lot of
people had um body doubles right like
it's it's a different voice and actor
yeah
when she has a helmet on for um
Mandalorian yeah I'm sure it most It
Fabulous
seems like a nice Gig if you're if
you're oh yeah one of these um Pedro
probably had to work a lot less hard on
this season than last of us he's got to
keep the helmet on all year long yeah no
no no uh why would you want to have any
facial expressions from anybody on
screen why wouldn't you just want a
bunch of Magneto helmets just uh not
emoting and standing around yeah that is
compelling television yeah I feel like
it works better when there's like one or
two mandalorians and then everybody else
gets to be a person with a face I don't
know it's just a thought just throwing
it out there there's a couple faces keep
going
Bays with baby Yoda in season two Disney
took one look at the toy sales and said
um no now it may not be super clear
while they're still together make up
your mind whether he's an actual baby or
just a baby they're forcing to be a
Child Soldier yeah
I'm under the impression that he's 50.
he's 50.
he just sounds and looks like but but in
a Yoda speech species you don't know
what that means does that mean are they
maybe you're a 50 year old baby you can
understand language
oh I think they're just doing a bad job
in the show of letting us know how old
he is I think at this point it like
sometimes they treat him like an actual
baby right but then other times they're
like okay stay right behind me while we
go kill moff Gideon like the most
dangerous man in the Galaxy that is a
baby as a child you are bringing him
into
controlling his own killer robot even
what are you doing I agree so yeah let
us know in the chat is it how baby is he
is such a baby in human years give us
what you think the age range of grogu
would be but is he uh but to me it's
it's an adult who's trapped in a baby's
body it's like I can only my vocal cords
aren't developed to where I can form
words and bodies on developer I can well
he can flip around speaking of which hey
I brought
let's wait let's wait till it's the top
we want to toss the base the volume here
and keep playing
proceed
and whether it's special effects
so yeah pause let's recreate some ilm
magic Daniel let's just play catch with
the baby and see if it looks it looks
manual why yeah
[Laughter]
I really brought this so the boys would
have something to do
it
give it a flip give it a flip yeah give
it a little flippity flip a forward flip
yeah
wow all right come back at you
well done well done
movie Magic
I don't know why we did that it just
seemed fun fun I just wanted I just
wanted to throw my toy that's how they
did it let us know let us know if that
looked uh Mandalore behind the scenes
that's how it was achieved on set oh
he's wrinkly just like a real Grandpa uh
all right keep going
foreign
[Music]
looks pretty good our version looked
pretty good
it's so fast the one thing they do know
is his name baby Yoda his name is grogu
sure if you say so
meet every other Mandalorian figure sold
separately battery's Not Included the
Jedi aren't the only reclusive maybe
celibate religious sect with a thing for
Orphan boys the words of the cree
collect a whole clan full of these
posable disposables like the armorer one
of the deadliest Hammer fighters in pop
culture non-incest division
[Music]
John favreau's literal self-insert who
spawns with the op chain God and still
can't survive the season
[Laughter]
in the waters of Lake Minnetonka and
gets called to resolve mandalore's deep
cultural divides ninety percent of which
are helmet based so pause
complaints about this series in this
show is like bocatan was a much more
compelling character in the cartoons so
Survivor found her incredibly generic in
this one yeah it's really Riding High on
the fact that we all love Katie yeah
it's really resting on the fact that I
thought that this is a I love her
complete repeat of was it Boba Fett or
season two or something who knows I
don't have the dark saber I need the
darkness to be legitimate I didn't win
it in the right way now you got in the
right way it's like it seemed like a
complete redo of what I knew about her
already yeah there was a lot of
recapping also in this both of the last
season and of in books
where it's like if you're gonna have
like your big reunion with them they
should have saved that for season three
and not used it all in Boba Fett just
don't hurt my baby yeah yeah did my
emotional support grow group it totally
felt a little repetitive from season two
it it just feels like
those scenes in the opening of this
season when Mando goes to visit her and
is like hey I need your help you know
bringing you back on this mission that
was where you needed to establish her
personality her motivation like give her
a character give her a journey to go on
yeah and because
he doesn't really have one so you're
kind of hoping that she's gonna be the
driving force between like why what are
the stakes of this story why do we care
about them retaking Mandalore and
literally instead of any material to
establish that she is sitting quietly
staring off into space like literally
instead of a where we established
who she had in her life why does she
needs for it why should we care chilling
chilling with a Droid friend I don't
want to go anywhere well that's not
interesting you're not that's not
it's not telling you and then like Dory
yeah
the religious divide or whatever you
want to call it
call ilorian fundamentalists yes like
reformers divide like it went the
opposite direction that I thought where
it's like oh she's gonna she's gonna
open up Mandalorian society when she's
actually like no I've found Mandalorian
Jesus again she's Orthodox me yeah okay
all right
um so not the most compelling
um stories first but I think that could
work all of this stuff I think there's
there's so many storytelling elements in
here that you could have arranged into a
story yeah like the deprogramming of din
Jared sure or like the mythosaur and
like her seeing the mythosaur unlocks
this like she didn't believe in all of
the mythological underpinnings of
Mandalorian culture but now seeing this
I mean like you call it the myth you're
gonna think it's made up the most Star
Wars thing
I was a kid that's up there with um yeah
like that's that's a story that I think
you could you could make compelling as
this person who didn't believe she just
wanted power but now she sees this
creature she realizes all of the stuff
that she rejected as a kid is true
that's interesting but like they don't
really give us that they present that
information so that people can yell at
me on Twitter that that's what's
happening that's not really what the
show's about it's different to put
something in than to actually do it
exactly like they've left that there for
me to find and pick up and make into
something compelling but it's not
compelling on screen yeah all right keep
going
helmet I removed my helmet and now I'm
an apostate I'm guessing that helmet
isn't coming off again and have you
removed your helmet since how do you eat
when other people are around you don't
when you get your food you go off to
find a place where you can take off your
helmets remove your helmet oh yeah
we'll go smooth it if you keep your
helmet on trust me sure you don't have
to wear the helmet at all times but
listen to your boy Pedro he knows what's
up
once you're done suffering through
baby's first and or episode Empire
rebels new Republic I can't keep track
one episode so corny you'll barely
notice it's about the heroes putting
down a slave rebellion is there no room
for a little bit of forgiveness so pause
like if people got like hung up on the
the lizzo like oh Jack Black like this
is so corny but to me that story was
about the droids being like we do all
the work for these people yeah and like
droids as we know in Star Wars are
sentient and they have feelings and
lives and stuff like that yeah and
they're completely leaning on them to
create this paradise literally on their
backs and they're starting to get ideas
they're starting to get ideas and like
quick Mandalorian like put them back in
their place and he does and then they
like have a hug and he gets a he gets
put into the nobility the ruling class
he gets knighted then they get to talk
to their friends in the field next door
the way Jack Black and lizzo in their
world is introduced leads you to think
there's a sin
because it's like well this is too
perfect they're being too cordial
everything's so nice there's got to be
an explanation yeah and no no it's like
no they're good and it's like we should
just have Droids do all the work for us
so we can live these these like lives of
yeah that was wild that was like but it
yeah like we're constantly muddying the
waters on whether like how sentient like
droids are because they don't they
didn't decide on their own to start a
rebellion Christopher Lloyd put
something in their drink he talks about
their oil sludge that they have at their
Droid bar does not make sense they're
not smoking smoking those Jazz
cigarettes walking in white women
Shadows
you see so but yeah but what you're
saying again is like the better story
but they didn't do that story they did
this weird alternate version where it's
like no the droids are very happy to be
slaves it was just Christopher Lloyd got
in their heads yeah yeah I think it
became very clear that they were slaves
when they allowed in Star Wars vision
for the Droid who wants to be a real boy
oh yeah
oh yeah there's like like
his name is Toby it's a Roots reference
folks it's a shout out
40 year old references yeah yeah I mean
it's they keep hint it's like a running
joke at this point that like droids have
feelings and and cry when they're hurt I
don't know how you come back from solo
where it's like solo like the the Droid
is a very three-dimensional character
who wants her Freedom who recognizes
understands what Droid writes means and
and not only does she not get her
freedom but she's then uh permanently
locked into the CPU of the Millennium
Falcon for all time it seems cruel and
horrible I don't know how you come back
from that and you don't even get to
flirt with Lando all the time like she
used to like at least if there's still
some that good land of flirting but then
like Lando comes back as an old man and
like touches the console I was like oh
my God it's like his ex-girlfriend is in
there this is so dark his ex-girlfriend
is literally one of the toilets yeah
and he hasn't been on the ship for years
and he comes back and he's like hey baby
how you doing like this is so messed up
like Oh you mean since you sold me to
your friend yeah so we could navigate
quicker I guess or something like this
is cronenbergian yeah she's horrible oh
well and or season two we'll see we'll
see what comes up uh Emo's got two plus
yeah keep going
fast and like five different episodes
where a giant monster pops out and says
boo
you should just do a Kaiju movie right
finally through at the return of moth
Gideon he's back with a brand new super
suit I have created the Next Generation
Dark Trooper suits
the show to where Dave baloney is more
comfortable the
cartoons Grand Admiral thrawn's return
will Herald in the re-emergence of our
military and provide commandoth huts
time to deliver
spin-offs can can I just go so scale
back your expectations after Andor way
back if that is
because even though Star Wars is for
everyone Disney has lost sight of what
made it special in the first place
going the [__] away every once in a
while
yeah I gotta say don't have an idea for
a Mandalorian season or if you don't
want to just make it the fun Western
adventure grogu and din show
you could have just waited till Ahsoka
right just yeah or just I mean they
they're they own the platform they own
everything you don't have to make it the
Mandalorian season three just make it
like mandalorians or like the fight for
Mandalore like do a new thing you can do
a special yeah you can do a three
episode Special yeah it doesn't need to
be like a new if you don't have a season
in mind that arcs and works like a
season do something else yeah yeah or
make 24 episodes I think they got to go
back to do make the Mandalorian like a
42 episode
like get real Hercules with it okay
today they founded they found an elf see
look as soon as we go back to those 24
episodes it's gonna be a lot of walking
and everyone's gonna complain yeah a lot
of reusing shots even though they're
like oh another Village that's being
pillaged by Pirates better stay and help
them yeah every week but like but that's
fine that's okay that's okay yeah have
them unlock new pieces of armor like
Mega Man and but that they actually
season one they're they did kind of hint
that that's what it was going to be
almost like a video game where like he'd
go and he'd get best car yeah add on to
his suit but then they they got bored
with that right away I gave him a whole
suit everyone's got like multi-colored
action Suits now
um oh well uh let's do start
the blast of us now that I have my new
body I can defeat those blasted girls
three Settlers of Catan Alan Smithy it's
free real estate turn your head and move
the spy who bugged me the Clone Wars
outer rims convenience what are you
carrying a gun for in case someone steps
to you Snoop Dogg nuke shots of the best
a pirates leave for me this is not the
greatest Star Wars character in the
world this is just a tribute fluted and
booted and as Tim Meadows considered a
cameo or just an actor who's still
getting work these days
the other thing yeah
which is why
okay it's official the prequels did look
better despite coming out 20 years ago
all right
[Music]
hold on yeah yeah they did that looks
way better
get out of here man though you don't
want no part of this
[Laughter]
all right so
um that's even the prequels look so much
I I love Ahmed best I thought that scene
was cool it's nothing against him but it
doesn't look as good as not at all yeah
they're at the volume doing that that
was definitely a volume yeah yeah some
kind of green stuff your eyes can sort
of tell he's just he's just doing this
yes and they're painting everything in
behind him hey man they got
they gotta make Skeleton Crew they they
lose the studio in an hour and they
gotta they got a strike coming they
gotta they gotta bang this out
um all right thank you so much uh for
watching and liking and subscribing and
hitting the Bell which if you haven't
you should uh we do this every Tuesday
along with other things
um we have some outtakes let's watch
them now
starring the unbearable weight of beskar
the show is good but it can be better
the yodelorien I'm 50. I'm also 50. come
on she keep my saber Bowflex goal leader
standing by this is the weight of my
hammer crushing your skull Follow the
Creed funko pop presents new month
Gideon blackberry and Target exclusive
Dark Helmet better call Maul Sean Carlo
Exposition the boring identity a top
secret double reverse anti-rebel I'm a
cloner Dottie a rebel fully vaccinated
Rangers of the new Republic orange man
good in the show Fast like And subscribe
the Pink's job the way of the gun gun I
am brute tree beard The Empire Strikes
black loquacious D teach me how to
dutchie glumplizzo
Mando without a plan though
called of no personality Galaxy side
quests the to-do list
adopt don't Shaw
the actress playing Elia Kane was also
gentura in quantumania she spent so much
time in the volume this year her eyes
are still adjusting to Natural Light I
liked it uh Gluck [__] oh sorry
everybody it's the internet me of like
when you make up a Star Wars character
name that's not real like oh and did you
notice the Easter egg back there
oh well I wish I knew I wish I was born
up on the Internet yeah
um all right let's go on to your
questions uh speaking of which Trevor
copter asked what other shows need a
lizzo Jack Black episode so many divert
yeah I would say you know what would be
great is like SVU like they were two of
your suspects of the week that'd be
great yeah I just started watching 9-1-1
because I didn't realize how Wild that
show is
yeah the first episode is like uh uh
there there's a toilet baby
um there's yeah this is what it's got
everything
so that would be the one that I would
put them in would be either that either
that or Abbott Elementary which is the
easy one because it would be really fun
yeah that'd be cute yeah she could do
that yeah
um throw them in succession you know
they could they could be like a
children's show host or something like
that uh throw them on on um uh the bear
maybe the Bear yes there yeah like lizzo
lizzo Works she's she's uh helping them
out in the kitchen Jack Black irritable
customer oh no
[Laughter]
I don't think this is their fault I
think no I think the way that episode
was written was really weird and they
didn't really give them real roles to
play and it was very much just like hey
look at look who it is it is everybody
and like if they'd given them more to do
I think they would have been fine yeah
it was definitely like the police clap
of the Mandalorian season three episodes
so frog eater rights do you think the
reason season three of the mandalorians
suffered in quality from the last two
seasons was because all the resources
went into making uh Soca the great Star
Wars story of 2023. I hope so is that
true that would be amazing and that
would have that I'd have a show to look
forward to yeah I do feel like it was
very stripped down in terms of like
Talent they just I I just checked
scanned through the writing credits it
was right basically like fabulous yeah I
think he co-wrote like two episodes with
somebody but he otherwise wrote the
whole thing so may and they lost again
the cinematographer and the the music
the Boba Fett show also felt a little
like slap Dash that was also our comment
when we talked about that was like maybe
they weren't red maybe this was like not
a thing they were planning on doing and
then Disney was like no we really want a
Boba Fett show like yeah so I I mean
both can be true yeah I mean I'm tempted
to say that no this is just what these
shows are like now but maybe we'll see
another maybe Ahsoka will be amazing
we'll be like oh they definitely
diverted resources I hope so I would
like that very much uh Lewis Valenzuela
as thoughts on the Meg 2 trailer will
Spencer stay I
the trailer looks great I felt really
burned by that first Meg movie because
that trailer also looked great and then
the movie was boring but this one is Ben
Wheatley did you guys see that
British cult horror filmmaker Ben
Wheaton oh let's go he did free fire he
did uh kill list he did that one in the
earth a few years ago he makes weird
messed up crazy ass movies let's see if
he can survive so yeah like him being on
board for big too makes me feel like oh
maybe this is gonna be amazing and I'm
definitely gonna have to check this out
the meg2 trailer has a shark eat a T-Rex
which it does it's from the books so you
know it's gonna be good remember these
are all based on novels so I hope they
stay true to the Meg Cannon and we're in
good hands yeah if you guys have not
seen kill lists seek seek it out amazing
low budget UK horror film yeah uh James
bunt says is it possible that it's not
special anymore for Star Wars and Marvel
has more to do with the TV rather than
the movies that are being made oh I
think so that's true for sure yeah I
think that uh uh a hundred percent when
it's the movies are it's interesting if
you think about Marvel if you Stripped
Away every Disney plus series from it if
it would still have more of a
event feeling yeah when a movie came out
probably I still think so yeah I think I
think you they they needed to be a
little more careful than they were about
not uh oversaturating the market and now
there's just so much you could you feel
confident missing a Marvel or Star Wars
thing because you're like well the next
one will be in a few weeks yeah um a
templates should they have just reworked
this season into a full-on Anthology in
the new Republic ERA this there was
already that Rangers show that was
canned uh from Gina Carano was it yeah
yeah nope
um so yeah that that would have been I
would love an anthology series for in
any era of Star Wars I think that's
really freeing and would be a reason to
tune in week to week if the if the
overarching storyline isn't hitting I
just I want I want there to be more
richer storytelling than what they're
doing which is tease something and then
show it to you so like there's a Rancor
Boba Fett has a ranker maybe he's gonna
ride it one day and then four episodes
later he's he's right again like that's
the least satisfying level of
Storytelling and I feel like that's what
we keep ending up with and so whether
it's an anthology whether it's a full-on
new show whether it's eight shows that
all combine into one show I don't really
care I just want it to feel compelling
week to week like there's a reason for
me to keep following it not just like
well we're gonna see a mythosaur
eventually yeah and which I'm sure we
are
lose phones I like this did you hear the
theory that MAF Gideon we see as a clone
only because he doesn't have a mustache
I'll believe in cloning but I can't
believe that a man could shave a
mustache that's that something's off
something is definitely that's how you
know the evil not getting because you
gotta goatee of course uh and Pat magana
will wrap with this uh what's your Star
Wars project pitch even if it's just
like you know General uh world and and
point of view uh I'd like to hear it
even if it would inevitably be canceled
by Kathleen Kennedy yeah
yeah I mean I I did like the um was it
Rogue Squadron that that uh Patty
Jenkins was working on like Top Gun Top
Gun in space right yeah I'm down
actually Pilots with the X-Wing Pilots
one yeah I like that that'd be fun I
think there's I don't know how seriously
they want to make it because it ruins it
makes everybody the bad guy but like a
dreads rights movie would be fun uh or
some kind of droid Uprising or or
something about that world that hasn't
really been or the cartoon droids let's
just remake that uh workplace comedy
workplace comedy Star Wars Drive yeah
yeah I always uh one thing that I the
rise of Skywalker that I thought was
interesting and I was hoping we would
see more of is everyone kind of
realizing that like oh Stormtroopers
aren't um clones anymore they are now
like
um kidnapped children or whatever yeah
and then but they like kept yeah and and
so as
um as like the slaves are like coming
out and and joining the Rebellion people
are still shooting at the other
Stormtroopers even though now we know
that they were like raised as babies so
I would be I would be interested to see
like uh uh something about like the the
uprising and like you know going through
and trying to get more of the Storm
Troopers to like change because actually
humanizing them and making them people
that made that really interesting to me
that they're not just action figures
walking around in suits that's good yeah
I pitched this before but I think uncut
gems but it's wado uh yes world of pod
racing yes he's way over I left he's
he's got a lot of guys coming after him
they're gonna bust his wings he's got
and just like CD pod racing gambling
addicts like stuff like that get this
real ground level Tatooine Moss Eisley
like real scumbags betting on the pod
racing and yeah like softy Brothers yeah
yeah give me a safety Brothers but it's
it's uh waddo no makeup they're just the
softy Brothers yeah
[Laughter]
okay done yeah sold and definitely
canceled by Kathleen Kennedy we get two
episodes deep but they'll be the best
two episodes
you don't even want to know man
um next week we'll be back next week uh
for um again an unexpectedly fun one wow
we did not expect this to have as much
Charisma as it did uh so I guess we just
got a lucky roll and uh that's a clue
we'll see you then thanks so much for
watching bye-bye
[Music]
thank you